-Welcome back, everyone.
I am hanging out with
the one and only Tracy Morgan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Currently the star
of "Coming 2 America."
We're about to face off
in a game called "Box of Lies."
-♪ Box of lies, box of lies ♪
♪ Box of lies, box of lies ♪
♪ Box of lies ♪
-Yeah.
I can't even look at you.
You make me laugh.
Here's how it works.
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
take out the object,
and describe it
to your opponent,
and they have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth.
We'll play three rounds.
All right, Tracy,
you pick the first box.
-You want me to pick that box?
-Yeah, I want you --
-Well, then that box
is being picked.
[ Laughter ]
Ahh!
I pick 5.
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You pick 5.
-I hope there's something
in here to cure my sciatica.
[ Laughter ]
-Pick 5.
Here we go.
I'm not looking.
I can't see nothing.
All I can see is just your face.
So you got to play
either you're lying already
or, like, maybe
you don't think that's funny.
See, that's the tricky thing
about this game.
Already you can be
playing the game
before you even started
playing the game.
-So I got to tell you
what it is, right?
-Yeah, describe it to me.
-It's a drink.
It's one of these fruity drinks.
-Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
-It's a fruity drink.
-Okay.
-With a little munchkin
on the top with a Yankee hat.
[ Laughter ]
-Fruity drink with a munchkin --
-Looks like my cousin Russell.
[ Laughter ]
You know exactly --
It's from McDonald's.
-Eh?
-Russ love these drinks
from McDonald's.
-Oh, so you're talking about
a Shamrock Shake, baby?
-You know what?
This a Shamrock Shake?
-Yeah.
-It's a Shamrock Shake.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, hold on, hold on,
hold on, hold on, hold on.
So you think it's a --
it's a Shamrock Shake.
Your cousin Russell --
You've seen Russell
with this object?
-Russell stayed with them.
-He stayed with McDonald's
all the way through --
-Shamrock Shake.
Yeah, he'd smoke weed,
and then he'd drink it.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, gosh.
[ Sighs ]
Gosh.
-Roll the dice, baby.
-I know, I got you, I got you.
I got you.
I'm gonna say...
[ Drum roll ]
You lie.
-You know what?
I ain't lying, brother.
-[ Laughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh!
He was wearing a little
Yankee hat, there you go.
[ Laughs ]
All right, buddy.
I thought Russell got me
on that one.
All right,
it's my turn to pick a box.
Here we go.
Which one?
Up here.
Something close to me?
-1! 1!
-The deuce, the deuce,
the deuce.
-Jump on it.
-[ Groans ]
-[ Grunting ]
-So heavy.
-Right. Okay.
-See what I'm saying, dude?
-Yeah.
-I'm in there already.
I'm playing around,
jumping rope,
I'm Double Dutching
in your head right now, dude.
I'm like...
♪ Miss Lucy had a ♪
♪♪
-I got to meditate
and go into my powers.
-Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
-My Spock powers.
-Mm-hmm.
-I'm a Vulcan.
[ Laughter ]
From the first "Star Trek."
-Okay.
It's, uh, Baby Yoda.
-Baby Yoda?
-Yeah, and there's money
coming out of his mouth.
[ Laughter ]
-Yoda don't even like money.
-That's probably
why he's throwing it up.
-He owe Luke some money.
Why you think him
and Darth Vader had problems?
-So you think I'm tell --
-I think you lying.
You might even be habitual.
[ Laughter ]
-You're correct -- I was lying.
You got it.
You got it, man.
Look at this thing.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, you know me too well.
All right.
Let's do one more round.
This one's worth 10,000 points.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
Tracy, pick a box.
-I'm asking my squad.
Which one should I pick, y'all?
-9!
-6!
-Number 1!
-All right, here we go.
-I picked 4.
-Cuatro.
-Pretty heavy.
-Ooh.
Sounded heavy.
-You ready?
-Whenever you're ready,
tell me what's in your box,
dude.
-Well, I'm gonna tell you --
Oh, man, this is dope.
-[ Chuckles ]
This is dope.
All right.
Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-You ready?
-I was born ready, man.
-I think it's a...
It's a cake.
-Yeah, gotcha.
-On a young
Arnold Schwarzenegger.
[ Laughter ]
And it say,
"Don't skip leg day."
-Okay.
That's what he always said.
So you think it's a cake --
You think that what is
in your box is a cake with a
young Arnold Schwarzenegger?
I'm saying what, teens, 20s?
Mr. Universe type of jam?
-Late 20s.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and underneath that,
it says --
-I can tell by his calf muscles.
[ Laughter ]
I need to ask you a question.
-Yeah?
-Am I lying, or am I not?
[ Drum roll ]
-He means business, man.
It's for all the money.
For all the marbles.
[ Drum roll ]
[ Laughter ]
You lying.
-[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
-What in the what?
"Don't skip leg day."
Gosh darn it!
Man, you're good!
You are good!
The best right there!
Tracy Morgan, everybody!
His new movie,
"Coming 2 America,"
begins streaming
on Amazon Prime Video tomorrow.
The one and only, the best in
the biz right there, come on.
That's what I'm talking about.
Stick around for more
"Tonight Show," everybody.